نفذت الشرطه الالمانيه عمليه دعم واسعه
شملات 11 ولايه وشاركت فيها 3000 بالافراد
وحدات النخبه في جهاز مكافحه الارهاب
واستهدفت عمليه الدعم بالاساس اعضاء في
حركه مواطن الرايخ قاد الادعاء العام انهم
كانوا يخططون الاقتحام البرلمان
والاستيلاء على السلطه وتنفيذ هجمات
المسلحه على مؤسسات تشريعيه المانيه اخرى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مصارعه نبداها بحيثيات ما
وصفته سلطات الامنيه الالمانيه بمخطط
انقلاب عسكري ما هي الخلفيات التي تقف
وراء هذه الاحداث ثم نتساءلو كيف ستنعكس
هذه التطورات على المشهد السياسي في
المانيا وعلى حاله الاستقرار في البلاد ثم
على اي نحو نقرا ردود الفعل الاقليميه
والدوليه على ما اعلنت السلطات الالمانيه
بالمخطط انقلابيين وتعاملها معه
[موسيقى]
مخطط للانقلابي من العيار الثقيل وبمشاركه
اشخاص كثيرين ومن مواقع مختلفه تجمع
بينهما تجمع بينهم خلفيه يمنيه متشدده
وهدف جوهره استعاده الدوله الالمانيه وفقا
تصورهم معطيات وتطورات اعلنت عنها السلطات
الالمانيه تتضمن عمليه دهن واعتقالات
واسعه نزلت الى احد من الصوره النبطيه عن
المانيا الديمقراطيه المستقره وقاطره
الاتحاد الاوروبي التي ترفل في الرفاعي
والاستقرار بحسب بيانات الادعائي العام
فان عددا من جرى اعتقاله وصل الى 25 شخصا
جميعهم اعضاء فيما وصفته بالتنظيم
الارهابي اثنان منهم زعيمان في التنظيم
وفقا للدعاء العام الالماني فان المتهمين
اسسوا نهايه تاشرين الثاني نوفمبر 2000 20
تنظيما ارها لمحاربه مؤسسات الدوله
وممثليها وقال الادعاء العام ان المتهمين
اسسوا ايضا ذراعا عسكريا بعض اعضائها
خدموا في الجيش الالماني وهدفها القضاء
على دوله القانون والديمقراطيه على مستوى
البلديات والمقاطعه وذكر الادعاء العام ان
اعضاء هيئه المركزيه لتنظيم يجتمعون
بانتظام منذ نوفمبر 2000 و 2020 من اجل
التخطيط للاستطلائي
على السلطه في المانيا وانشائها لدوله
خاصه بهم وفقا للادعاء العام فان نقطه
انطلاق تحقيقات كانت صله بين اعضاء
التنظيم واعضاء مجموعه الوطنيون المتحدون
الذين تم اعتقالهم في ابريل الماضي على
خلفيه التخطيط لاختطاف وزير الصحه
الالماني كارل
هذا وقد اشد وزير العدل الالماني ماركو
بوشمان بتفكيك ما وصفها بالخليه الارهابيه
مؤكدا ان ذلك يثبت قدره المانيا على
الدفاع عن ديمقراطيهتها
هذا وقال الكريم ان العمليه الامنيه ضد
حركه مواطن الرايخ شان داخلي الماني بحث
واضاف لكريم لانه لا يمكن الحديث عن اي
تدخل روسي في التحضيري للانقلاب في
المانيا كما نفه السفاره الروسيه في برلين
اي علاقه مع ما وصفتها بالجماعات
الارهابيه مؤكده ان المكاتب الدبلوماسيه
والقنصليه الروسيه المانيا لا تقيم
اتصالات مع ممثل جماعات الارهابيه او
كيانات غير شرعيه اخرى
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا بالبرلين ياهو
فوق الخبير بالمجموعات اليمنيه الالمانيه
المتطرفه
الالمانيه والاوروبيه اهلا بكما ضيفيه
برلين
الالماني بالقول بان
المانيا القدره للدفاع عن ديمقراطيتها
عندما يتم الحديث عن فكره انقلاب عسكري
محتمل في المانيا الى اي مدى نحن امام
صوره صامده للديمقراطيه في المانيا
حسين كامل
باننا الديمقراطيه قويه نستطيع ان ندافع
عنها وان السلطات
وضباط الامن
يجدون مهاجمه هذه المجموعات الصغيره التي
تريد مهاجمه
الجمهوريه الفدراليه الالمانيه والاطاحه
بها وانما حصل هذا
كان موقفان حاسما من قبل السلطات لمكافحه
هذه المجموعه الارهابيه متطرفه يمنيه
عندما يتم الحد يبقى معك سيد اهونك عندما
يتم الحديث عن مجموعه الى الان الحديث على
انها تتجاوز العشرين الف وانها توغلت حتى
في بعض المؤسسات العسكريه القوات الخاصه
هل المدينه تكلم عن تاثير محدود
صدقوني
مصالح الامنيه
ومجموعات صغيره اخرى ضمن القوات العسكريه
بعملهم خطير جدا ولو كذلك لا يواجهنا
مشكله كبيره
مجموعه ارهابيه يمنيه كانت موجوده قبل 20
سنه هؤلاء تعلموا الدرس منهم
سك سك
ان المؤسسات الامنيه في جمهوريه المانيا
تعلمت الدرس تعمل خط وبخطوه
وبطريقه حاسبه جدا خلال السنتين وثلاثه
الماضيه لهذا السبب نجد انهم كانوا
حاسمينه جدا اليوم والا لما فعلوا ذلك سيد
مصطفى السليمي من خلال متوفر حتى الان من
حيثيات ومعلومات قدمت حول هذه الشبكه وما
جرى معها من قبل قوات الامن والجانب
القانوني ال- ال- الالماني كيف يمكن رسم
الصوره امنيه
من الناحيه الامنيه يمكن القول ان جماعه
مواطنون رايح هي جماعه اسست منذ 40 عاما
كانت تنشر كخلايا صغيره كمجموعات صغيره
بافكار متطرفه عبر الشبكات موزعه منتشره
والان تقدر يعني اجهزه الاستخبارات بان
اعضائها ربما يصل حوالي 21000 لكن من
الناحيه الفعليه فان ربما يمتلكون مواد
مسلحه بامكانهم ممارسه
انه حسب التقارير ايضا انه في السنوات
الاربعه والخمسه الاخيره بدات ترتفع نسبه
الاعمال العدائيه او اعمال العنف والاعمال
الارهابيه التي ترتكبها هذه المجموعات
وهنالك بعض الخبراء يقدرون بانه وقعت
عمليه همم يعني ردي كليزموس يعني عمليه
تتطرف في داخل هذه المجموعه واقترابها
مزيد من الاق نحو العنف وفي القانون
الالماني عندما يكون شخص يحمل افكار يمنيه
متطرفه ويمارس اعمال العنف ولا ولا يؤمن
بالقوانين ولا يؤمن بالدستور ولا يؤمن
بمؤسسات الدوله فهو يصنف متطرفا
متطرفا بينما حسب القوانين ايضا بالمانيا
انه مثلا حزب اليمين الشعبوي الحزب البديل
الذي يحمل افكار شعبويه ويمنيه ايضا طالما
هو يؤمن بالقانون فهو يظل ضمن القانون
وليس بنيه المتطرفا وانما يمينا شعبولا
وهذه التقديرات الحقيقه في القاموس
الالماني فقط وهي تختلف عن فرنسا بلدان
اوروبيه اخرى من الناحيه الواقعيه فان خطر
هذه المجموعه قائم لان
بغراء من الناحيه العمليه التخطيط
لاستهداف اهم مؤسسه سياديه ترمز للسياده
الدوله والديموقراطيه في المانيا
كان ضمن السيناريو كان يريدون ان تتم
العمليه في البدايه مهاجمت البرلمان
والاعتداء المسلحه اليه واعتقال عدد من
الساسه والبرلمانيين وبعد ذلك
يعولون ان تقع اضطرابات وتنضم اليهم وحدات
من الامن لدعم محاوله الانقلاب من الناحيه
الفعليه يبدو هذا سيناريو همم
غير واقعي وفي حاله حدوثه لا يتوقع ان
ينجح لان المانيا هنالك التجذر
للديمقراطيه وهنالك رفض مطلق في اعماق
المجتمع الالماني لفكره النازيه والفكر
الصيني همم السيد همم قبل اشهر الاجهزه
الامنيه كانت قد حذرت من هذه المجموعه
وحذرت من خطرها وارتباطه بالوضع الاقتصادي
في داخل المانيا نتيجته خاصه ما يجري في
الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتالي الى اي مدى
التقليل من حجم خطر هذه المجموعه اذا كان
الوضع الديمقراطي في المانيا مرتبط بشكل
اساسي بالوضع الاقتصادي
اي داونلود
بهذه الطريقه او الشكل هل هناك حرب
اوكرانيا
ندعم اولئك الذين في حاله خطر وما الى ذلك
ان هذه المجموعات هذه المجموعات الصغيره
انه دعونا نقوم بشيء واذا لم تحتوينا
القوات الامنيه
بعد سنتين سنكون مصدر خطا اذا هذا هو خطر
بهذا المعنى
والدائنا موجود ان بعض مجموعات صغيره تكون
ومياله الى العنف ومهاجمه الناس
والمهاجرين ومهاجره السياسيه
لكن هذه كلها اعمال محدوده جدا الى حد
كبير
رغم انها قد تنالت في سنوات الماضيه وخاصه
اثناء الجائحه
من مقارنه بالماضي
ان هذا الهجوم اليوم جارا على الايه ثلاثه
الاف ضابط شرطه وبالتالي
بان ضباط الامن والموسات الامنيه تعي بشكل
كبير وواضع في مساله
ايقافهم والهجوم عليهم وانهائهم هذه نقطه
مهمه وابقي معك سيد فوقي اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف من عناصر الشرطه قاموا بهذه العمليه
جرى مداهمه اكثر من مئه تقريبا حوالي 35
موقع بما فيها مواقع داخل مراكز امنيه
وهمم عسكريه تحذير من قبل المخابرات
الالمانيه ومع ذلك ترى بان الخطر ما زال
بسيطه
يسديد
القوات الالمانيه حريصه جدا
ان لا تعرض لهجوم من مميت وقد حصل ذلك
وبالتالينا
تقدموا مهاجره هذه الاماكن باعداد كبيره
لمحافظه هؤلاء اعداد الصغيره من الناس
ومحاصرتهم وسيطر عليهم اذا كان الامر نوع
من اظهار القوه
الناطقك
ولكن هذا لسه انك حتى عناصر تشبه ما يحصل
في حروب الاهليه اذا ما قاف فهمتوا قصدي
هذا مجرد تسمع مجموعه صغيره قد تكون خطيره
جدا اذا لم تتحطم ولكن حطمت انهيناها
الامر يختلف ما حصل قبل 20 سنه عندما كانت
قوه الامنيه قد
تتجاهل هذه المجموعه ليس خطره ورغم من
خلال مجموعه ارهابيه يمنيه
تعلموا الدرس من الماضي خلال هذه السنوات
عشرين وبهذا كان هذا لا يعني انه قد لما
يكون هناك في محاوله لكن
لكن هذا ليس باي شكل همم حركه قويه وهذا
النوع من العنف اللي من لدينا كثير من
الحركات الاخرى في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي والتظاهرات وايضا لدينا الحزب
السياسي اليمني اي اف تي ولكن هذا يختلف
عن استراتيج
محاربه او حتى ارهاب بالجمهور هذه
المجموعه الصغيره اما حاولت ان تقوم به
بطريقه خياليه غير واقعيه
في المستقبل القريب لولا انهم قد قضي
عليهم اليوم
سيدنا موسى
عندما نتكلم على فكر متجذر في المانيا
يعود حتى ربما سنه
94 الذي بني على اساسه هذه المجموعه
مواطني الرايخ عندما نتكلم كما اشار اا
ضيفي الى مثل مساله صعود اليمين في
المانيا بهذه الصوره عندما نتكلم عن وضع
اقتصادك الذي حذرت منه المخابرات
الالمانيه تعلق بالمواطئ الالماني وانزعاج
جزء منه لما يجري من انفاق على الحرب في
اوكرانيا هل ما زلنا نصر على ان الوضع
محدود ويمكن السيطره عليه
ان يتم التوضيح انه بالنسبه للمشاهد
العربي انه نحن لا نتحدث عن سيناري
وانقلاب مثل ما يحدث في دول لا توجد فيها
مؤسسات ديمقراطيه متجدره نتحدث عن محاوله
عن تخطيط لاستهداف مؤسسات سياديه في
الدوله يمكن تقريب الصوره مع تصغيرها
كثيرا عندما هاجمها مؤيدون للرئيس السابق
ترامب الكونجرس الامريكي رغم حجم الرئيس
وكان الرئيس له نفود له طيار واسع من
الحزب جمهوري الحاكم سيناريوهات مهاجمه
المؤسسات الديمقراطيه الان في الغرب في
الديمقراطيات الغربيه اصبح ملحوظا في
السنوات الاخيره بسبب تنام التيارات
الشعبيه هذا المعطى المعطي الثاني هنالك
اوضاع يستغلها هؤلاء المتشددون اليمنيون
منها مثلا عندما وقعت موجه استقبال
اللاجئين في الم عندما وقعت ايضا جاء احد
كورونا في حرب همم اوكرانيا الان
وتداعياتها على المواد الاساسيه وعلى
الطاقه وتذمر الشارع الالماني هذه معطيات
بمجملها تشيع التذمر والمتطرفون اليمنيون
يحاولون التوظيفها لاحداث نوع من القلاقل
والاضطرابات ولكن ما مدى قدرتهم على تنفيذ
همم خطتهم هذا موضوع يتم تقديره لحد الان
معظم المراقبين في المانيا يقولون ان ذلك
هو تاثير محدود وقوات الامنيه تستطيع
السيطره لكن هنالك ايضا اراء تقول انه في
السنوات الماضيه بل في ال 20 سنه الماضيه
منذ احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر وبعدها
ركزت الاجهزه الامنيه في المانيا وفي
الغرب بشكل عام في دول الغربيه على مساله
الخطره الاسلامي او خطر التنظيمات
الاسلاميه
واغفلت خطر التنظيمات اليمنيه المتطرفه
بل انه حتى تم استهداف اليهود باعداد
كبيره وتبين ان الذين يقفون وراء هذه
العمليات في معاهدات السميع هي جامعات
يمنيه متطرفه وبالتالي يمكن القول ان
الاجهزه الامنيه الالمانيه نفسها تدرك انه
وقعت اختلالات في السنوات الماضيه
هنا سؤالي للضيفه يا سيد
صوره مشوشه تاتي من المانيا بين من يقلل
من حجم ما جرى وبين من يندر بان هذا خطر
شديد وربما يمكن او يصعب على الحكومه
الالمانيه السيطره على تنظيم او كيان
موازيك الذي جرى الكشف عنهم من خلال هذه
المنظمه
مواطني الرايخ
من خلال متابعه بسيطه ردود الفعل على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي كان هناك تساؤل
الى اي مدى سوره المانيا الديمقراطيه قد
اهتزت بعد هذه العمل البعد قال عندما
قرانا الخبر انقلاب عسكري في المانيا قرا
ان الخبر مرتين المانيا انقلاب عسكري هل
اهتزت هل تاثرت صوره المانيا بعد هذه
العمليه
صغيره
انا اؤكد
انقلاب العسكري غير مقبول غير غير ممكن
الماضي
ليس هناك اي مؤشر يدل على هذا الشيء طبعا
نحن همم
من هذه المجموعه ولا بد ان نخشى ان بعضهم
اغتيال سياسي ما حصل قبل ثلاثه
ااا سينابون مهاجمه
الكنائس
المعابد اليهود
ولكنها احصن مثل هذه الاعمال بيننا نحن
اخر لكن
العنف ضد مهاجرين او ضد مجموعه من الناس
او سياسيين حتى
اطلاقا طيب يبقى معي الا دقيقه واعذرني
السيد
منصف الاسليمي متعلق برد الفعل الالماني
هل هناك عقده في طبيعه رد الفعل الالماني
التاريخ الالماني معروف خاصه قبل الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وبالتالي في التقليل من
حجم اليمين المتطرف وتنظيمات مثل هذه
العقده التاريخيه حضور في طبيعه المشاهده
والمقاربه الالمانيه في رد الفعل في دقيقه
او افتكرنت
اعتقد ان الثقافه السياسيه الالمانيه
تطورت بشكل دؤوب خلال العقود التي اعقبت
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ونحن الان نلاحظ انه في كل مده ربما بشكل
دوري تظهر موجات من العنف اليمين المتطرف
وغالبا ما يتم نهج اساليب طويله الامد في
احتوائها غالبا هنالك رغبه في عدم اظهار
حجم كبير لكن في الغالب يتم احتواء
الظواهر على ما دامني ولا يتم همم
العمليات بشكل سريع ولذلك نتائج عملي
النصف هو التي اشار لها زميل قبل 30 عاما
منصف سليمان
الالمانيه والاوروبيه شكرا لك وكذلك ضيف
من برلين السيد
الخبير بالمجموعات اليمنيه الالمانيه
المتطرفه شكرا جزيلا لك
كتاب الحلقه
[موسيقى]